the Florida students behind the never
again movement hope to build on the
momentum created by their March for our
lives protests over the weekend hundreds
of thousands of people gathered Saturday
in Washington and around the world to
demonstrate against gun violence Adriana
Diaz has been following the Stoneman
Douglas students she's on Capitol Hill
now with the latest on their story
Adriana good morning good morning the
Parkland students say their March here
in Washington was just the beginning and
now they want to turn their voices into
votes at marches nationwide this weekend
nearly 5,000 people were registered to
vote many of them Millennials who here
is going to vote in the 2018 election an
ocean of activists delivered their
demands at top volume we're just sick
and tired of waking up every day scared
to go to school
the crowd was silenced for six minutes
by Marjory Stoneman Douglas student Emma
Gonzalez and a little over six minutes
seventeen of our friends were taken from
us she and other core organizers from
Parkland appeared on Face the Nation
Sunday we're gonna be revving up for the
election this is not the end this was
just the beginning
the group is already working on their
next steps including a call for town
halls nationwide on April 7th a second
national walkout on April 20th and a
voter registration campaign to register
teens before November's midterm election
trust not all students feel included in
the movement parkland student Kyle
cashews I agree with incompleted that
this cannot happen
ever again but I differ with them on
what policy needs to be made a host on
NRA TV also criticized the students
calling them hypocrites they hate
machines that cause death except hold on
no you ain't never gonna take their cars
away but senator Tim Kaine said Congress
is already building on the work of the
movement but the activism of these young
people is actually changing the equation
just the two things that we put into the
budget bill the other night couldn't
have been done had these youngsters not
advocated for them the spending bill
passed this week does include minor
improvements to background checks now
the students held their march in the
shadow of the Capitol but with Congress
in recess lawmakers weren't there
still this week state lawmakers in New
Jersey and Vermont will vote on tougher
gun laws
Anthony Adriana Diaz thanks Adriana